kann man beiden den sieg überhaupt noch
wegnehmen wir müssen warten bis
ausgezählt ist und ich glaube was beiden
gesagt hat ist dass alle geduldig sein
müssen das gilt für die amerikaner aber
das gilt auch für uns wahrscheinlich
wird er das ding gewinnen aber man soll
den tag nicht vor dem abend loben
[Musik]
definitiv ja
joe biden kennt deutschland ich habe
ihnen auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz getroffene kennt
europa ich habe mir noch mal im
europäischen parlament getroffen
er ist jemand der alliierte verbündete
freunde schätzt und er weiß um den wert
von solchen freundschaften weil er
verstanden hat dass freunde amerika
stärker machen und das hat trump er nie
verstanden
so wurde es trotzdem die meisten
konflikte zwischen deutschland und
beiden geben sollte er denn jetzt
präsident werden
naja ich glaube es gibt zwei drei themen
bei denen es jetzt nicht einfach so easy
weitergehen wird also die demokraten
sind was den handel an geht er so ein
bisschen auf abschottung aus bisschen
protektionistischer das war jetzt der
tramp auch aber für sozusagen eine
exportnation wie deutschland wir
verkaufen autos wir verkaufen maschinen
und anlagen da ist es natürlich immer
ganz gut man hat einen präsidenten der
sich auch darum kümmert dass der zugang
zu den märkten gut funktioniert zweites
thema wurst kritisch sein könnte ist
nord stream 2 mit russland und dann das
dritte thema das ist die frage wie gehen
wir mit china um also welches verhältnis
haben deutschland und europa zu china
und wie sehen die amerikaner das denn da
ist auch bei den demokraten die
überzeugung dass man hart mit china
umgehen muss und unsere wirtschaft ist
in china sehr engagiert wenn sie gerade
russland und china könnten diese beiden
nationen jetzt diese unübersichtliche
situation in den usa man weiß ja auch
nicht wie lange das ganze noch mit
gerichtlichen prozessen so weitergeht
aus nur zum beispielsweise für
cyberattacken
ja das ist erwartungen die die experten
hier bei den sicherheits instituten alle
haben das eine richtige verfassungskrise
in amerika sollte es dazu kommen
für feinde für gegner amerikas natürlich
eine chance bieten schaden anzurichten
und das eines insiders packen das haben
sie völlig richtig gesagt das andere ist
die große befürchtung dass china unter
umständen gegenüber taiwan aggressiv
auftreten könnte vielleicht bis hin zu
einer militärischen aktionen und das
sind natürlich dinge die einen sehr
nervös machen müssen deswegen ist
eigentlich nur ein wunsch zur zeit der
entscheidende
wir müssen uns wünschen dass das
verfahren in amerika sauber zu ende
gebracht wird und ein klares ergebnis im
wahlmänner kollegium in diesem elektro
college für beiden dabei rauskommt wir
denken sie denn sollte ein klares
ergebnis rauskommt dass trump dann auch
freiwillig seine niederlage einräumen
wird und aus dem weißen haus auszieht
nein das erwarte ich nicht ich lasse
mich gerne überraschen trump ist schwer
vorherzusehen also wenn beiden jetzt
alle staaten gewinnen sollte sagen wir
mal so dann ist der vorsprung so groß
dass ja auch eine erfolgreiche klage in
einem der staaten gar nichts mehr ändern
würde aber wenn das knapp wird also wenn
beispielsweise ich weiß nicht 10 15
stimmen über den 270 sind und man kann
dann einen starken herausbrechen und
kriegt dann die wahl gedreht dann wird
trump auf jeden fall auf jeden fall die
gerichtliche auseinandersetzung bis zum
ende führen und das kann dauern und das
wird schwierig mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren